معنا من بيروت الدكتور منير شفيق الكاتب
والمفكر الفلسطيني دكتور منير مرحبا بك اذ
تقترب هذه الحرب من اتمام شهرها الثالث
منذ بدء عمليه طوفان الاقصى في السابع من
اكتوبر في تقديرك مع هذه الخطوه التي اعلن
عنها جيش الاحتلال من سحب عدد من الالويه
وتسريحها للعوده الى انعاش الاقتصاد وما
الى ذلك ما الذي حققه الجيش الاسرائيلي
خلال هذه الاشهر الثلاثه تقريبا خلافا
لتدمير قطاعات واسعه من قطاع غزه وقتل عدد
كبير جدا من المدنيين جلهم اطفال ونساء ما
الذي سيستطيع نتنياهو تسويقه في الفتره
القادمه بعد هذا القرار من
الجيش بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في الحقيقه
لا شيء يستطيع تسويقه بعد بعد هذه الحقائق
ان النتائج التي اسفرت عنها المعارك
البريه كلها انتهت بخسائر فادحه بالضباط
والجنود
والاليات والدبابات واظهرت فيها قوات عز
الدين القسام وقوات سرعيه القدس والمقاومه
عموما مهاره هائله في التصدي للقوات
المهاجمه الهمجيه الجانب الوحيد الذي يمكن
ان يتباه به وهو عار عليهم هو الهجوم على
المدنيين وعلى قتل المدنيين وعلى تدمير
العمار
والقتل المتعمد الذي يجعلهم يدخلون في
نطاق جرائم الحرب وجرائم الاباده والتي
ستشكل هذه جميع جميعا سبه عار في جبينهم
وسوف تؤثر برايي على مستقبل الكيان
الصهيوني عندما يفقد كل الهاله التي بناها
عندما تشكل قامت على الاكاذيب والتي انتهت
بهذه الرؤيه الفاجعه بدوره كمجرم حرب
ومجرم وقاتل للمدنيين وللاطفال اما على
المستوى الميداني وهو المستوى الحاسم الذي
تدور رحاه في الحرب الميدانيه ف هنالك قول
واحد اكيد انه هزم حتى الان هزيمه وان ما
ينتظره في المستقبل القريب والابعد هزيمه
نكرا اشد مما حدث له الان الحقيقه الذي
يفهم في العلم العسكري والذي يقدر الوضع
بالناحيه الناحيه العسكريه يجد اننا امام
قياده صهيونيه منسلخ عن الواقع
وتتحرك بناء على الرغبات والاهواء وروح
الانتقام ولا تتحرك على اساس رؤيه دقيقه
لميزان القوى وللنتائج الواقعيه على الارض
لاحتساب الخسائر هي اصبحت الان منسلخ عن
الواقع هي في عناد وفي تحدي لميزان القوى
في الميدان اولا كما على مستوى الدماء
التي اسيل واساءت لسمعتها وكانت يعني دماء
اقوى من الصواريخ واقوى من سيفهم وكذلك
النتائج العسكريه كلها تشير على الى ان
الهزيمه تنتظرهم لذلك انا اعتقد ان ميزان
القوى الميداني والاقليمي والعالمي يسير
بصوره مضاده ضدهم يوما بعد يوم وانا
استغرب اي جنرال عسكري درس في المعاهد
العسكريه او قرا فون كلاوس او جميني او
ليدل هارت يستمر في حرب خاسره بهذه
الطريقه التي يقود بها نتنياهو والقاده
المشاركين له المعركه الخاسره يعني هذا
السير على طريق الخسران بهذه الطريقه لا
يفعله عمليا رجل عقلاني وانما يفعل فقط
المقامر الذي يحاول ان يشتري خسارته
بخساره اكبر لينتهي اما الى الانتحار او
ينتهي الى التسول في الشوارع هذه العقليه
المقامره لا بالنسبه للعلم العسكري يجب ان
تكون غريبه عن العلم العسكري وانا اعتقد
انه من حسن الحظ انهم يرتكبون هذا الخطا
الفادح من الناحيه العسكريه والسياسيه
سواء في الجريمه التي يرتكبونها بحق
المدنيين والتي اساءت الى سمعتهم ام كان
ذلك من الناحيه العسكريه التي اثخن فيها
بالجراح وبهزيمة
كيف ممكن لما بتقرا عن عدد الدبابات وعلى
عدد الاليات التي دمرت حتى الان وعدد
الجنود والضباط حتى الذي ي يعلنون ه هو
كاف لان يوقفوا هذه الحرب والذي ينظر الى
ما يجري من راي عام ضدهم وهذه مساله يجب
ان لا نقلل من اهميتها والتي
اخذت تضيق الخناق على بايدن وعلى نتنياهو
وتزيد من عزلته الدوليه هذه مش مساله
بسيطه الناحيه الثانيه ان الوضع الميداني
الذي انتهى الان على ما هو هو اخذ ايضا
لاظهار التصدع الداخلي في الكيان الصهيوني
يعني مش قليله انا بتصور انه بالامس يرفض
جلنت وجانتس انه يشاركوا نتانيا في مؤتمر
الصحفي يعني هذا الثلاثي الذي يقود الحرب
هو على هذه الدرجه جا من التصدع هذا يعني
اننا اصبحنا قريبين جدا من نهايه هذه
المعركه